[Musique]
on retrouve Mélanie poket pour notre
rendez-vous dédié au plus jeunes bonjour
Mélanie vous allez nous parler atelier
créatif bon oui et même art plastique
atelier d'art plastique et plus
exactement ceux de l'école municipale
d'élancour qui donne qui sont donné à la
ferme du Mousseau il s'agit de
développer la créativité des enfants il
découvre toutes les techniques des arts
plastiques de l'acrylique de la peinture
du fuseau du fusin ou encore du pastel
il travaille sur plusieurs supports du
carton du papier de la toile ou encore
du tissu alors le samedi matin c'est une
session pour les 79 ans c'est un bon âge
pour débuter ce type d'atelier créatif
alors je suis pas plasticienne alors le
plus simple pour y répondre c'est
d'écouter Floriane fagot elle est
professeur d'art plastique pour l'école
municipale c'est une tranche d'âge qui
est la plus propice pour pour découvrir
encore toutes les techniques parce que
passer un certain âge 12 13 ans c'est là
on va plutôt être sur de l'apprentissage
un peu plus académique pousser des
techniques avant bah ils ont encore
cette cette curiosité et ce plaisir de
de toucher à tout de vouloir tester
toutes les choses donc c'est vraiment
une tranche d'âge intéressante alors le
jour où nousous sommes rendus à un
atelier il faisait du collage il
travaillait à partir de papierers de
magazine écoutez-les en fond c'est pour
faire le ciel par
exemple euh en fond ça peut être aussi
le fond du
mur ça peut être ce sont des couleurs et
sur ce fond et ben on fait des motifs
quand je seraai grande je voudrais faire
architecte et ça m'aide beaucoup là je
vais faire mon fond avec des écritures
de papier
et après quand j'aurai tout fini je vais
essayer de faire ma mongolfière avec les
montagnes et tout ça on va faire une une
exposition et donc on va coller tout ça
sur une feuille après on va prendre des
trucs par exemple comme ça on va faire
un fond d'un d'une
couleur alors on l'a entendu Elline
vient juste de parler d'une exposition
qu'est-ce que c'est et oui une
exposition parce que depuis ce vendredi
les œuvres créées par les élèves de
l'école municipale sont à admirer c'est
résonnance un rendez-vous et l'an
courtois qui a aujourd'hui 25 ans se
artistes professionnels ont été retenus
par la commune eux il sont à découvrir à
la ferme du Mousseau et les enfants sont
les œuvres des enfants sont à découvrir
à la médiathèque des7 Mar c'est à
découvrir jusqu'au 4 décembre on écoute
Laurent mazori le maire adjoint culture
d'lancour le thème de l'air que nous
allons traverser et les artistes qui
exposent les artistes que nous avons
choisis avec ce jury ce sont des
artistes qui en utilisant toutes les
techniques bien entendu les techniques
pictural les techniques du travail sur
le son sur la lumière sur les volumes
sur les différents éléments vont nous
transcrire quelle est leur vision de
l'air comment on le comment on le
transporte et oui car on peut
transporter l'air comment on le traverse
alors on va terminer avec les
informations un petit peu pratiques
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'inscrire à
ces ateliers alors déjà il y a plusieurs
créneaux disponibles les cours d'art
plastique se font le mercredi et le
vendredi après-midi ou le samedi matin
pour ce qui est de l'âge on peut
commencer dès 4 ans et c'est jusqu'à 18
ans il y a aussi des cours adultes vous
pouvez trouver tous les horaires sur le
site de la ville qui s'affiche sur
l'écran les enfants non'ont plus laisser
libre cours à leur inspiration et
laisser libre cours à leur créativité
également merci beaucoup Mélanie poquet
de nous avoir présenté ses ateliers on
passe